I want you to leave more comments for
each other so while ago I did a video
when I was at the airport topic of that
video was asking people to leave more
comments on the videos not just my
videos but any videos because for
creator someone who's making videos
those comments like that's the lifeline
that's that's that's that's blood that
that keeps you going and I'm spoiled now
that I get a lot of comments and you
know don't don't stop writing because
that makes me happy but I get a lot of
comments and seeing how might be does
are impacting you keeps me going but
leaving comments in other people's
channels as well and you might be the
only comment on that channel and that
comment that you make could be the
difference between them continuing on or
not it's really hard for somebody to
have the courage to make a video put it
up on YouTube you know self criticize a
ton and then have zero momentum where
one person just that one person leaves a
comment that could make the difference
for them to want to keep going and for
those of you who are making videos you
know what I'm talking about
so that was that video and what I want
to talk about today was I want you guys
to leave more comments for each other
and I think it's great to see all the
comments come in on every video and I
really appreciate it but I see that
there's very little interaction between
you guys where you'll just leave a
comment for me and answer the question
of the day but then not respond to
anybody else and I feel like we could do
a better job as believe nation as a
community to help each other out myself
and Nina we try to leave comments and
respond everybody who leaves feedback
but you know how good you feel when you
get somebody who pushes you and who
believes in you and gives you advice and
I want you guys to be that change for
each other I want you to when you come
to a video of mine and you leave a
comment use the beatty a hashtag but
then also leave one more comment for
somebody else scroll down on the page
and find the comment that you know you
can either you can either offer some
advice some feedback too or just say
congratulations or give some words of
encouragement
cuz that gives you an opportunity to
have a meaningful impact on somebody's
life that day and and you know as much
as I like being a spark for you guys I
want you to be the spark for each other
as well and I think it'll make you feel
great it'll definitely make them feel
great
it'll help spread more believe and I
think just make the world a little bit
better of a place so the next time
you're leaving a comment use the beatty
a hashtag and scroll down and leave one
extra comment every time you watch a
video just to show somebody else some
love on the channel
so my question today is what do you need
help with right now what's what's the
most pressing issue in your business
that you'd like some advice or feedback
on leave it in the comments below and
then for the people who have commented
already leave a comment to respond to
somebody else and show them a little bit
extra love and support thank you guys
for watching continue to believe and
I'll see you soon